and you can see that these two factors
here and you have a leading coefficient
and what you do is these points here m
and n these are the x-intercepts okay
this is where the graph crosses the
x-axis and by setting these factors
equal to 0 you can find the x-intercepts
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go through this doing an example if
we set X minus 1 equals 0 we're going to
get x equals 1 ok so that means it's
going to cross right here at 1 if we set
this factor equal to 0 X minus 3 we get
x equals positive 3 now we know where
the parabola crosses the x axis now if
you find the midpoint between these two
x-intercepts here you can see it's x
equals 2
okay that's our line of symmetry okay
that's what divides the parabola in half
but if you had a little bit more
challenging one than this you can just
add those two values together and divide
by 2 that's just how you find the
midpoint you add them together divide by
2 that's 4 over 2 which equals 2 now
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the x coordinate of the vertex
which is this axis of symmetry here
which is x equals 2 and we're going to
put it back in for X okay we're going to
solve for the y coordinate of the vertex
so we have y equals 3/2 minus 1/2 minus
3 so we get 3 times 1 times negative 1
which equals negative 3 so that means
that our y coordinate of our vertex is
going to be over here at negative 3 so
now we have three points we can draw a
pretty good parabola using those